All right, welcome back to the show, everybody.
We're going to do calls today, but we're doing
them a different way because of all of the
complaints about the call quality on the phone
line.
We are going to, for the first time, try taking
callers through discord, which is David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
So let's just try it.
OK.
We're going to go first to Rachel from Arizona.
Rachel from Arizona.
You're the first caller on today in terms
of using the new Dischord system.
Welcome.
Can you hear me?
Can we hear you?
I can hear you.
Can you hear me?
Rachel, you're coming through clear.
Crystal clear.
How are you today?
Good.
What's what's on your mind?
Well, after that dumpster fire of a debate
off my young age of.
I don't think there was a clear winner on
either side.
So, I mean, listen, I agree with you that
it was a mess and Trump's strategy was to
make debate impossible.
I do think that on balance, like, it's hard
for me to say because I'm in this like I'm
not the target of this debate.
You know, I'm voting for Biden and I'm very
clear on that.
But I think the big picture is Biden looked
stable and Trump didn't.
And I think that if we imagine a casual political
observer.
Sure.
People who want like an alpha type that insults
everybody.
They might be drawn to Trump.
But I think it probably is better for Biden
how it went.
Right.
I agree with you on that 100 percent.
I mean, compared to Trump, Biden just look
like a saint, right?
Compared to him just, you know, his hot headedness.
And it was it was definitely not the norm
for a presidential debate.
Now, let me ask you this, Rachel.
As someone who follows politics, do based
on how that debate went.
Do you feel any need to watch future debates
or are you sort of like good for the rest
of this election?
I just want to watch it for the pure, you
know.
What's Florida, the entertainment value, like
a train?
Yeah.
The came in, it's like riding, right?
You just can't look away.
Yeah.
See I think that it's hard for us to analyze
it because I'm trying to think of people who
are watching it to try to figure out who to
vote for.
How are they seeing it and might.
We'll have to see in the coming days how the
polling shifts.
But my instinct is it did more more damage
for Trump than it did for Biden.
Right.
And I am I'm originally from Ohio.
And so I have a lot of people on my Facebook
and Instagram from Ohio.
Yeah.
On I was kind of interested to see their take
on it because a lot of money for Trump.
Right.
And, you know, they're just making excuses
for, you know.
You know, he he got the hardest questions
and.
Oh, that's interesting.
Because so.
Because one reaction would be to insist that
Trump did great and he won.
But what you're seeing is people aren't saying
But they're excusing the fact that he imploded
by saying he was he got the hard questions
and whatnot.
Correct.
That's interesting.
That's different.
I mean, I think that signals it was worse
for Trump because they're not even able to
just claim he won.
They're having to make excuses for the performance.
That actually is interesting, right?
I mean, that's all they've done for the last
four years, isn't it, as Yankees cases for
him?
Very true.
Rachel, thank you for the call.
We're in Arizona.
Are you?
I am in Tempe.
Tempe.
OK.
I've never been there.
I've been to Tucson.
I've been to Phenix.
I've been to some wineries down closer to
the I think senorita near the Mexican border.
Beautiful, beautiful place.
Yes.
It's very gorgeous, especially right now.
It's like just a little above 100 still.
And it has perfect weather, but it's a dry
heat.
So it's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what they all say.
All right, Rachel, I know you're having me
on.
Appreciate it.
We'll talk to you.
I love your show.
Thanks, Rachel.
Great to hear from Rachel.